I'm helpful advice with Bobby kalila and
the skyline of LA that's you that's me
that's already asked the industry
question here so you guys answered it
pretty well already so well like those
you know what though people like it yeah
so I am Twitter a couple of guys said we
like it when you talk about Hollywood so
we're gonna we're not gonna stop doing a
lot of our own helpful advice are those
so you guys will really answer that so
we'll go to the very bottom one get out
his oozes take on this high Tiger belly
there's a cute asian girl in my chem
class but I want to talk to but I only
see her Tuesdays and Thursdays I'd sit
next to her but she has a close group of
friends that box her into the corner
seat I'm an Asian guy 23 and I'm a big
fan of the show how do I approach her
any techniques hey-zeus it's to pull I
know exactly how I know how you feel not
you what you do is you go up right and
you compliment all the girls the friends
the friends like let's say the girl's
name is Sally mm-hmm you go to the front
Sabrina Sabrina I like your hair
hey Katie I like your eyes your great
eyes then you look at the one you like
and you go yeah all right yeah you hurt
them a little plastic naggy it's negging
I mean yeah a little you hurt them a
little did you get in their mind there's
books written about it Bobby necks you
and you're in love with him yeah yeah
that's not what he does is not nagging
that's domestic abuse Arvin seven on
your titties are like forcing it's so
consensual what do you do I want to do
that right now I'm gonna eat it and I'll
just grab her titty like aggressively
consensual I let her leave but like
Alina claw in a chloride
yes your take
oh my take on that let's see why way I
have you before before you answer that
yeah I just say one thing what's going
on Bobby
I have a question real quick
yeah yeasts I wanted to break this up so
far don't forget so just real quick I
was at work today and every day I go to
work mm-hmm there's a little kid that's
on the show okay family show and this
little kid sander just listen he punches
me in the butt yeah that's cool from
behind he'll just start punching me in
the bottom right and you know everyone's
around people are laughing so I'll laugh
all right but I get angry nothing I
could do about it I said stop and he
just keeps he's like eight he's very
talented
yeah but he just loves it it's fine yeah
but it's like what do you do you can't
do nothin so unhelpful advice for Bobby
what should Bobby doing this unhelpful
advice I think you should run oh I'm
sorry
right what do I do just run don't I do
run away a little bit and her mom go
stop it Sandor stop it every time he
doesn't run to the mom great that's
great about where she's aware ah
yeah I I in my head I imagine you
laughing and pretending you're enjoying
it can I punch him back but he can yeah
right you can't put your just hold him
no all right anyway so answer the
question of the lady uh-huh or the guy
how does he get how does he talk to the
girl how does a girl you should walk by
but like hey I got the answers to the
test right here and there on this table
so if you want to sit I don't know real
good yeah I like what did you get your
lady we we met at Bed Bath & Beyond
that's a say we work there and then she
you work out which department to be on
Park patronising where did you word you
what department did you work in towels
be real yeah towels
yeah but just have this Connie supplies
huh me real cleaning supplies has towels
Oh supplies come on let's be real
towels all right Tom as you're folding
yeah we were just folding towels and
stuff and
yeah and then and then what happened
well I met her in the break room and
like hi and she's like you're a weirdo
I'm like all right I'll leave and then
we just would hang out but she wasn't
really into me and to begin with you're
like yeah yeah so cute yeah and you guys
I don't think I tried in the beginning I
used to try and tell people like I would
lie and be like well we met at a coffee
shop because that's where we went on our
first date he attended but then he would
be like no we did it [ __ ] tinder but
yeah technically you could say coffee
shop because that's where you officially
met Matt I would have never met her
unless it was tender why are they giving
us money to keep plugging them
everything you need anything else a plug
yeah um I'll be doing a one-nighter
at Ontario Improv November 12 you got to
go guys Ontario go check out my friend
Hayes is a trail how much is it probably
not that much right just sign up for the
email unless I'm sure you get the thing
they'll pay for the room for sure you
read it hey Zeus Trejo performing there
what's your handle uh Twitter ad hey
Zeus Trejo and then Instagram at hey sue
Strahan are number one and then has to
stray holcom Facebook fan page comedy
but yeah I will be at the on Terror
improv November 12 go see him guys
listen dude um we needed a guest today
and you came through I really appreciate
it I've always loved you and um thank
you for coming here on thank you guys
love you guys this is great i Volvo yeah
this is huge
I love the Polka pretty big fan base
yeah no I thank you for letting me
million downloads a month when did you
break your lenses a little while ago
wait but not like today then just today
well you don't have money to fix it I do
no how much did that cost III was a car
I I haven't
the pair that I use how much it cost to
fix that probably not a lot
I'll fix them here much [ __ ] question
you [ __ ] it bean I don't know what I
can't call them bean what's your little
LensCrafters
I don't know what's your Vettel people
actually racist now can I know go for it
why did the refri the bean its refried
of us oh yeah that's a good question
though maybe they forgot me I got the
answer
why didn't they do it again I already
fried it again see what happens
what accent is that I'm curious so do an
Asian accent I don't you try to try my
best
I don't know I try I try Bobby hey Zeus
everyone thank you guys okay yeah I'm
gonna stop calling it housecleaning cuz
someone's like why are you saying
housecleaning it's housekeeping I'm like
what ours is different everyone else
it's housecleaning we're back look you
guys be right back okay we'll be back
[Music]